[Music]
it's gonna be a crazy party is it like
your joint paradise you are mind games
and alcohol a psychologist on-site
monitoring every move and producers
still on lockdown instructed not to talk
to cast or the press we've learned the
powerhouse attorney Corinne has hired is
Marty singer who's worked with Charlie
Sheen and Scarlett Johansson current
statement to us says in part I am a
victim I had a little memory of that
night and she is dealing with the
physical and emotional trauma stemming
from that evening so now the question is
how much is the show to blame et on
lines lauren zima has been to the
paradise set so there are about 12 to 15
producers who work with the cast
directly most of whom are in their 20s
by the way and some of those producers
even drink with the cast they might say
hey let's go take a couple shots maybe
making the contestant feel more relaxed
but here's the thing
while there is unlimited alcohol on
these shows the producers are not making
anyone drink and yes finding love and
hooking up our points of the show but
they are not making anyone have sex
something else to note is that several
former contestants have told me that as
far as they know there is nothing in
their contracts regarding the
consumption of alcohol and nothing
ensuring them that they would be
protected if they drank too much